Her low freak bitches,
John Daly's character saying we're shows
a girl of the jerk and she hates it and,
and he breaks up with the cheerleader
at school because he hates the jerk.
Good for him.
I had said with a girl in high school
where she hated a e t and I and I was a
rough one to where it rough
and to survive back then. Yeah.
There's certain music and there's certain
movies that you're just not allowed to
like or hate. Yes. Yeah.
Well that's a funny thing.
My wife and I is, we violently
disagree on a lot of that stuff.
We don't have like one or two violently.
Yeah. There's, there's one or two,
like the main things that mean the most
to me in the world where my wife's like,
I can't, I can't, I don't like it at all.
And then stuff that she likes it, I go,
I hate that more than anything. I
think that's good. I think it's good,
especially with your spouse to have
like very few interests in common.
I think all those people
that do everything together,
a fucking Weirdos man.
They always freaked me out. That, that
is interesting. Yeah. Cause it's a,
it's like stand up. My wife, I met
her when I wasn't doing stand up.
I did stand up from the time
I was 17 until I was 24.
I met my wife when I was 28 or 29 so she
didn't know anything about staying up
till three years ago when I
started doing it again. Yeah.
What caused you to do that?
I remember when you started coming around,
everybody was like, look at Judd and
he was doing, it's funny, I, I uh,
I, when I stopped when I was
24, I was pretty burnt out.
So that was 92 and I was
getting a lot of writing work.
The Ben Stiller show got picked up,
this sketch show we did for Fox and that
kept me busy and I was making, you know,
a lot of money compared to
the $500 a week I was making,
doing stand up on the
road. And I thought, well,
this is the universe saying you don't
need to do stand up and you should stop.
Maybe your friends are funnier than you.
And I'm living with Sandler and I'm
hanging out with opening up for Jim Carrey
and it's,
it's daunting.
It's like trying to start a band
and your friend is John Lennon.
He just feel like it would be
weird to not feel like a dick.
I was cocky with Jim Carrey and oh
yeah, the funnier than this guy. I mean,
I'm a sane human being. I know,
I know what's happening. Um,
and I was also a little bored of it
because I was so obsessed since I,
since I was 10 and you know,
I did funny people,
I did a little standup to write jokes
for funny people. So I was writing jokes,
but it was for Adam's character.
And then I started hanging out with Amy
Schumer working on train wreck and she
would come back from these tours
and I just got jealous. I thought,
that sounds like the most fun thing.
And then one night I said,
I'm going to go up tonight
just to make you laugh just to,
so you could see what it was
like when I did stand up.
And then I told a couple of stories I had
told on talk shows and I knew would go
okay. And Amy was very excited
hoping I was going to bomb.
Like she was thought this
would be this funny thing.
Judd bombs at the comedy cellar and I
did pretty good just cause it's stories I
know work. Okay. And then the
comedy cellar, he said, hey,
anytime you want to come back,
just pop in, we'll put you up now.
No one ever said that when I was a comic
because it was hard to get stage time.
And I thought, wait a second, I'm
getting treated like somebody who,
who gets to show up and go on stage.
I have to take advantage of this.
And I went on every night,
the entire shoe to train wreck.
No matter what time we finish shooting,
I would drive straight to the comedy
cellar. Wow. And I had the best time.
And then I came back to la and started
doing the Improv and the comedy store in
Largo and, and then I would put these
benefits together at Largo once a month.
And, and to me that was the most fun
because I could book a show and get like
channeling to come and
Randy Newman or you know,
Aziz and Fiona apple and we
did them all his benefits.
And I always like
producing things like that.
And then slowly my act got to the point
where I thought, oh, I'm, you know,
I deserve to be here. This isn't
some freak show. Well, you know,
as the difference between someone who
writes for television and movies and,
and the difference between that and a
lot of standups is when you're making a
living, writing and producing
and directing and doing all,
you're disciplined you right? Yes,
actually. Right. You have notes,
you have books you have like
you're opening up your binder,
you've going over your stuff.
So many comics don't do that.
I remember when I started,
I was opening for Larry Miller,
one of the legendary Comedians, and
he, he would have these incredible,
but some of them were like 10 minutes
long. He had a great bit about,
uh, about drinking. It's one of
the best standup bits of all time.
And he had a bit about
Thanksgiving and a skiing,
but they were all like 10 minutes and
they would get funnier and funnier.
And one day he said to me,
you know, this is a job.
You got to sit down every day.
They'd write jokes.
You don't just go to the mall
and watch a movie every day.
Like if you sat down for two hours at a
desk and treated this like it was a job
that deserves your respect, you'll be a
hundred times better than everybody else.
Yeah. And I did listen to his
advice at the time, but I do now,
like now I sit down,
let's try to write it up.
Okay.
Yeah.